- Is this real?
(lighthearted music)
- So my good friend Kevin
is obsessed with mini pigs.
He only follows mini pigs on Instagram,
he talks about them all the time,
but unfortunately his
landlord has a no pet policy,
so he can't get one, but
today is his birthday,
and we wanted to make it really special.
So we're here in his
apartment to surprise him
with two baby pigs!
Also this is the very
first time that Kevin's
going to hold a mini pig, and so I think
his reaction's gonna be pretty awesome.
- [Voiceover] Surprise!
- What is happening?
What?
Whaaat?
(light cheerful tones)
Oh God, is this real?
What, what, what?
Oh my God!
- [Voiceover] Kevin, you can pet them!
- They're scared of me now!
Oh my God, my heart, I can't handle this.
Aw, they're so scared of me.
I've only seen them in pictures.
Oh my God.
- [Voiceover] Yes!
- This is the greatest day of my life.
This is a spiritual moment for me.
I don't know why I love pigs
more than any other animal,
but it's something about
like the little nose
and the little tail and their noises,
it, aw, it's just so adorable.
I always tried to convince my mom,
hey we should get a little pig!
Never let me have one.
Definitely the greatest day of my life.
I'm ready to buy 10 of these immediately.
Objectively so that I can lay down
and just let them run all
over me and cuddle with them.
That will be how I
destress every single day.
(pig squeals)
(laughs) No!
Ah!
I've lived the greatest moment of my life,
it's all downhill from here!
(lighthearted music)